[Musique]
on va parler aujourd'hui de mac on va
parler de macbook air on va parler du
mac mini parce qu'apple a fait une
présentation de tout nouveau produit le
macbook air qu'on pensait pouvoir
disparaître penser à voir arriver un
macbook pro un petit peu low cost
macbook
toujours est il que le macbook air est
toujours là il persiste et signe
on a un nouveau macbook air avec un
retina display de 13,3 pouces ce qui est
vraiment très intéressant est la grande
nouveauté là dessus c'est la présence de
deux ports thunderbolt 3 2 l'équipe
c'est apple évolué apple source ouvre à
l'usb tisser s'ouvre à la compatibilité
et ça c'est un point très positif
néanmoins ce qui est six coups là dessus
c'est une prise jack qui complètement
préservée donc une prise jack sur la
droite les ports thunderbolt roi sur la
gauche
au dessus une caméra hd pour facetime
pour tout ce que vous voulez pour
discuter avec vos amis farnoux skype est
ce qu'il vous fera plaisir qu'il nous
annonce un écran avec 4 millions de
pixels pas moins pas plus autre point
qui est intéressant c'est l'arrivée de
tom shayes dit alors c'est plutôt cool
d'avoir l'arrivée d'un coach heidi pour
venir déverrouiller avec un capteur
d'empreintes digitales sauf que ça c'est
pas nouveau c'est bien sûr se produit
effectivement sur ce macbook air c'est
plutôt bien il y aurait eu fayçal 10 ans
était vraie belle évolution ça aurait
été vraiment intéressant pour on va pas
cracher dans la soupe mais de ce côté là
il n'y a rien de bien révolutionnaire
apple nous annonce une sécurité accrue
notamment avec la puce t2 un clavier
papillon de troisième génération
toujours et trop éclairé un trackpad un
peu plus grand plus large de 20% des
haut parleurs stéréo avec plus de
puissance plus de bassins sont plus
claires bon roi jusque là tout va bien
rien de bien non plus folichon là dessus
à côté les performances vous avez une
intel core i5 à l'intérieur peut monter
jusqu'à 16 giga de ram maximum et vous
avez un ssd l'intérieur qui peut aller
jusqu'à 1,5 terrain mais on sait aussi
que le prix derrière va être assez élevé
en termes d'autonomie nous avons fait
une machine qui peut tenir jusqu'à 13
heures qui est surtout beaucoup plus fin
beaucoup plus petit 17% plus petit que
la génération précédente
donc un ordinateur qu'on peut emmener
facilement avec soit toujours par tous
un petit peu l'adn de ces macbook air
deuxième produit qui était présenté par
apple c'est le nous
vos mac mini plus de performances plus
de puissance plus de rap jusqu'à 64 giga
de ram plus de capacité de stockage
un ssd jusqu'à 2 tera toujours de la
sécurité avec ses fameuses puces t2 un
meilleur refroidissement toujours plus
ils ont fui en faire une machine qui en
termes de performance a l'air assez
intéressante en terme de collectivités
vous avez de l'éternel du thunderbolt
roi du hdmi usb type à vous avez
plusieurs versions mais si vous prenez
la version la plus boosté avec 1 100
vous pourrez faire du montage vidéo mais
sur sans aucun problème vous pourrez
travailler sur des gros projets autocad
faire des projets en trois dimensions
enfin dans la machine en tout cas est
assez sûr booster et ça c'est plutôt
cool que vous pouvez précommander dès
aujourd'hui qui sera dispo à partir du 7
novembre et au terme de tarifs ça
commence à 999 euros et ça va jusqu'à
1249 euros
un focus qui a été fait par apple et qui
est assez intéressant c'est de parler de
recyclage apple se met au vert c'est
déjà un petit moment
le macbook air ou le mac mini sont faits
à partir d'aluminium 100% recyclé des
machines qui se veulent beaucoup plus
verte et ça pour coup aussi il faut le
souligner bon il n'y a rien eu de bien
d'un go sur cette production le mac mini
ou sur le macbook air sont des nouveaux
produits dans la gamme pour moi le vrai
produit qui a retenu l'attention
c'est l'ipad prod mais l'ipad pro on en
parle dans une autre vidéo je vous
invite donc à vous abonner à rester
connectés partout dites moi ce que vous
en pensez vous est-ce que vous avez des
ordinateurs d'apple est ce que vous
trouvez ce macbook air intéressant
qu'est ce que vous pensez du mac mini
est ce que vous pourriez aller sur les
autres et puis vous invite aussi à vous
abonner
restez connectés parce que je vais
tester d'ici quelques jours le nouveau
macbook pro un des nouveaux macbook pro
en tout cas 2018 comme ça je vous dirais
exactement ce que j'en pense comment il
est la performance de clavier le cilss
avola on n'a pas merci à vous soyez ça
nous embrasse prenez soin de vous j'ai
hâte de lire vos commentaires et à très
bientôt
j'avoue
[Musique]